what's going on reject nation I'm Greg
Alba longtime follower of this channel
patronage AK do you recommend our
patreon of course I do what do we got on
there we got stuff now but hangouts my
personal favorite thing yes they're
currently full right now so let's not
promote that you know the TV reactions
which apparently I don't watch any and
them this is news to me what they're
good yeah and then the Q&A is which
apparently only watch one yeah also news
to me go check us out patreon thanks for
being here um you know how to pin the
whole thing yeah he has a movie review
channel make sure to go check it out and
you are you gonna buy the spider-man
game for ps4 that everyone's buying
already I mean I guess I'm gonna jump on
that bandage up on the bandwagon got do
what everyone else is doing right i GN
released the first 20 minutes of
Marvel's spider-man ps4 and I said let's
do it because I have not pre-ordered it
meaning I do not have a physical copy of
the game UI so let's just watch someone
else have fun with the game for a nap
wonder what that's not for you birth
spiders in this game
so far those pictures are the worst
graphics I've seen this kid but all the
moving stuff okay I'm looking forward to
this game you know this game looks
really good
seems like it could be like kind of like
the Arkham games were yeah yeah for
spider-man yeah they can use that Panda
[Music]
generic energy bars generic energy drink
he's editing on Final Cut Pro right
there okay now Wilson Fisk
damn son bikini
[Music]
all units little for mobilization
location efficient our disk spider
skills come in ahead thus have time to
first step on a day
I hope I would want a web on my toast
[Music]
Wow obvious
cool
hey your bills Peter I wish I had that
[Music]
it's like a day in the life with Peter
partner deals look at that man I got
beautiful that looks
you know that this looks spawning oh
we're actually playing now
Wow oh man I got a boy of it sooner and
[Music]
that
tower but still waiting on a warrant
mind if I join in on the fun you know
how the lawyers are that's very
exhausting all my I mean he just killed
eight years for this know will senators
leaky gas pad to Time Square sounds like
you guys are trying to keep my backup
for BG see you got it almost there
oh dude I love the different way he
swings and pulls off
yeah that's pretty pretty x2 web zip
whoo
websit hello Parker where are you we
must run through the demonstration at
least once before the grand committee
arrives yes sorry yes dealing with our
personal issues I'll be in soon promise
I'm gonna wrap this up quick then get to
my real job wonder what his real job is
he looks he sounds so exhausted
[Music]
[Music]
under fire bring in the hammer
[Music]
one of these mercenaries that was the
same yeah whoa that's one way to get it
get them out of the way
hahaha that's cool that's really well
repeat girl let's watch it some people
of the game I love it yeah these guys
are more dangerous
that's cool yes dodge quick web them up
[Music]
guys it's panel air launch oh yeah this
players clearly just pressing like the
same to money yeah fighting in the air
is safer good tip oh hello how he just
woke up five minutes ago yeah barely
walk down the stairs when I wake up Yuri
Yuri
my new booth would know quietly
Wow this must be so cool for people who
actually live in New York to play this
game you don't live far from New York
yeah I could see the New York skyline
from my house that's are pretty cool
they like the exploring in here yeah
this tower I like Trump's tower
maybe maybe most of this is actually
Donald Trump maybe that's what they're
going for in this game we're gonna lose
I'm gonna go
do your thing yes I like how some of the
characters
I got some of the characters are so
detailed and look so realistic look at
my catchment they're like Ionian photos
he just murdered that guy throw a guy
like David yeah
bill focus do you what you do not funny
smarter that guy yeah people one night
here with metal trash with like so much
I'm pretty sure he's there today who's
murdering people left and right whose
[ __ ] I'm pretty sure great guys all this
force is using on them boom
I love the wide variety of like
maneuvers and martial arts skills yes
gay man healed just like that doesn't
need to grab ratchets room it has to be
a play on trucktown all right looks like
ever been a trump town neither my night
live like near
[Music]
damn is matter combos such a variety
come on come on they shut the elevators
down take the stairs I prefer a more
direct approach
[Music]
oh cool oh I'm so glad they can be able
to love because yeah cuz it'll take
forever to crawl yeah in this this
really even the cries of the veg feels
like art them yeah okay server room it
is but like all spider-man style like
you yeah you're though he's crawling
here whoa there's a lot of structure
going on
if I have a water faucet on in the
background people can't hear me how does
she not hear the gunshot really looks
like he's getting more aggressive taking
these guys out I'd meet me through one
guy yeah just do all the evidence I
should look for a sneaky way yeah they
could even hit the scan II like it's
hard not to compare this game for so
many things that remind it yeah like
that's not necessarily a bad finish not
because ya know this is 100 percent that
it is like that the hardcore spider-man
version
[Music]
oh man
[Music]
see just how good their security
oh you guys forgot the latest kernel
patch this is the guy French clearly for
the search history three but that's part
of my charm isn't it
door down now
I'll make sure no one gets in their way
[Music]
look at God just disappeared on the
ground hey guys
I guess bombs are part of Willie's
Getaway Plan we look for the bombs
everyone will love the variety of them
how he sweeps the places yeah it's like
very straightforward he bounces off the
stuff yeah this is cool you got to help
people
oh when you're freaking out fast if you
can walk help the injured got it
it's not forever kind of gameplay
come on spider-man come on I wonder if
it's harder now that there's more smoke
on it yeah
[Music]
okay Willie coming your way
spider-man it's Yuri
how we doing captain could be better our
choppers took feeding better ground our
last one chopper we have no one is dump
it from landing and no one to chase him
if he flies away why do I get the
feeling that's what he was planning all
along because he probably was
criminal mastermind damn your did EMTs
up here fast
[Music]
yeah that's not spidey-sense it's really
good coming yeah I mean you would have
died yeah it looks like whoever's
playing a spider-man he hasn't gotten
hit one time I feel like it's impossible
complete in his cave yeah it's also the
first novel that's true
national rocket
the bomb squad guys get through this so
much details I love it when he just
throw something yeah okay must be
somewhere let's sleep flipping up there
okay
[Music]
you guys alright we were just about to
call for backup I think I'm in lead the
way
we'll be right behind we're good cops oh
yeah like like spider-man wouldn't hear
them okay there we go
some real Tuffy's alura's cracking jokes
this entire
[Music]
yeah that's so cool
slides our hey Yuri looks like some of
your guys were on Fisk payroll good news
is they were Willy's last line of
defense
I'm right outside his office with
pleasure
well he is that ketchup it stood offer
you forced him
that's pretty Meza writing your memoirs
don't forget the hyphen between spider
and man I forget there's a chopper ready
so I won't be long beat his head in with
a car door surprise this father but your
foolishness ends now
you do know I can still see you right Oh
[Music]
for me you shouldn't have [ __ ] i milked
it for so long Peter got hit you got hit
oh damn he's really good okay okay
very shortly I will destroy you
[Music]
now he's fighting Wilson miss Wilson
Fisk a super strength here's a big guy
yeah it's survival table hit again
[Music]
he's tough in the cinematic part I was
gonna say the same to you you know what
to do
[Music]
you're out of your depth it's like when
you fight baby in Pindar go ahead you
gotta find all the villains am tired
take does one thing I noticed is that I
don't think he has like a like a Spidey
no Wilson fish oh yeah Lucy does and I'm
just not seeing it but that'd be that'd
be something that I would like see you
know how far to go yeah
dammit look he's running all
web-shooters that's that's it that makes
sense
yeah actually think about
I love how seamless the graphics and the
Ceph attic which blends so well with a
man
can't let him die well I like that
that's funny
making a reference to the one movie yeah
you know what you know when something's
funny people usually laugh they don't
just go that was funny
well a little tip if you're at a comedy
show
okay you laugh you know go that was
funny
the distraction Tomic I've done several
videos on this spider-man game every
time I see something it just makes me
want to play it even more you know I
definitely gotta get it when I get back
yeah I love this first 20 minutes man
starting off with him in his morning
routine lifestyle he kinda reminds me of
the opening of Back to the Future for
some reason yes like brilliant dude who
doesn't do well his right away he has to
have such efficiency that he can't even
have time to push down the toaster but
Anini it's a [ __ ] toaster that was a
Beretta there just doesn't sell it he's
immediately on the go going through all
of New York I've said it many times with
the gameplay does are the guys who
worked on Arkham involved in this game I
would have to love that out there are
such similarities but in very
complementary ways I never mean it in a
sense of this is a negative or did you
like all the good qualities about the
army games like you see in the
spider-man game when it comes to the
Intel at the gameplay and like with the
spider sense abilities sometimes it does
that like x-ray vision that Batman can
do in Arkham and you see it here too or
even with the way he's like going
through the vents and stuff and the
different types of ways he attacks seem
so similar to that it's all good thing
yeah he's not moving like Batman he's
not doing what Batman does he's doing it
all in the way spider-man would it's
like Arkin game but instead of it being
Batman and spider-man and the whole
color palette looks like a spider-man
yeah I could do a lot brighter it's very
appealing stuff and I love to how it
seemed like as he kept going through
more levels and more bad guys to kind of
combos he was doing yeah yep changing to
the kind of kicks and punches he was
throwing kept changing up to he's not
just doing the same a new verse or you
have to like eventually upgrade to be
able to do more maneuvers yeah it just
seems that depending on the situation
every rat in the game his types of
fighting skills will change up yeah cuz
you know he's got you know just the
regular guys with the fight but then you
know he was fighting people with like a
rocket launcher yeah or just a machine
gun or there was a riot shield guy yeah
it seemed I could when I got emotionally
intense his his version of fighting gets
more mixed up in it I love the quick web
em up stuff then you know whether or
what he was in the vent any website guy
up immediately in the spiderweb I love
the turret you know web up and then he
doesn't use that to throw it at first
yes yes yes all the different variety
seems great and what I especially love
though is he's constantly joking yeah
yeah tired time you might miss it in the
middle of you focus you know what's
going on rebuttal you play that you
might not hear the joke he's making he's
constantly joking which is such a
spider-man thing to do like I at least I
don't remember the Batman games this
seems impossible to be defeated the
spider-man yeah it seems like it's gonna
be really hard to lose in this game I
just could do everything yeah but I mean
I imagine I mean this is only the first
20 minutes I imagined that it would get
harder as time went on I hope this gets
harder too I guess the only letdown as a
very this is me like nitpicking the only
letdown about it is Wilson Fisk is one
of the biggest bad evil ins in Marvel
and in spider-man yes well for him to
just be so easily defeated in the first
20 minutes of the game kind of weakens
his presence a little bit yeah I feel
like you know at least him like he's you
know strong guy but he's smart too so
like I would have thought of some way to
avoid this situation yeah I imagine this
is not the end of Wilson Fisk in this
game I imagine that I imagine this is
the set up for the store long because I
remember seeing some other images from
other trailers of well yeah yeah he's
being taken to jail I've imagined him
probably has him evolving when the
sinister six comes to play yeah I mean I
don't know who the big bad is in this
game yeah I feel like that he will and
should have a bigger presence in this
game he should hey he needs to cuz every
kind of a letdown if like out first 20
minutes it's a compelling it was nothing
yeah
like maybe like maybe this is all part
of his plans it's all part of the plan
yeah he wanted to because built their
drillin thing now right yeah Arkham
Knight wants to because yeah they always
wanted because plant it because
sometimes transitions from cutscenes to
gameplay can be very noticeable yes it's
like whether the cutscenes can obviously
be like super cinematic looking with its
letterbox and then the gameplay looks
very different and the graphics don't
look as good what I love is the gameplay
and cutscenes blend so perfect yes there
were times where I know we're in a
cutscene yeah it's very early on in the
game I'm like oh we're actually playing
the game that I thought we were still
watching the cutscene yeah I was like oh
you know he's not fighting fisca he's
fighting like years but it's a cutscene
yeah you're not playing like I would not
have noticed yeah you didn't say that
was great man I can't wait to play this
game I really can I like everywhere I'm
calling this freaking game it's sold out
right now one day I will pick it up my
friend andrew has it right now and not
me not different Andrew you're your
patron I love this guy
Andrew Gordon you know yeah yeah he has
the key he pre-ordered it so he has it
right you know my buddy
yeah and like got it and I know I can't
have I'm probably gonna play it for fun
right now yeah all my friends you know
what I'm gonna be doing for the next
month alright guys well you already have
the game have you beat it already are
you waiting for it to come in the mail
can you not afford it answer one of them
do you not like Spider Man's you know
like spider-man why'd you sit through 25
minutes of this you guys can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification Bell can subscribe button
suck fat balls these days and you can
check out Andrew Hayes I'm his channel
it's a really great channel I'm
subscribed you should subscribe to
almost at 100 Wow you could be lucky
number of 100 yeah 98 no just know you
might be that guy don't subscribe
take a subpage now I got who like TV
show reactions and weekly q and A's
would love to have specifically you
become a patron eject just you not the
other guy - yeah you not the other guy
watching with you he sucks